[Music]
talent and power are hard to assess as a
vampire
really stronger than a werewolf are all
angels stronger than
all demons here's a look at the most
powerful villains on supernatural from
strong to strongest
no matter who alistair is currently
possessing he's always one of the most
powerful demons hell's grand torturer
answers to few
save high-ranking demons like lilith
he's tasked with torturing dean for
about
four months in earth time in order to
free lucifer from his god-built
cage although dean is a human and
alistair has
home court advantage in hell the thought
of any entity having the ability to hold
dean
down for that long further proves that
alistair
isn't a normal demon his biggest claim
to fame is playing a role in triggering
the apocalypse
even so he's no match for sam
wielding the full force of his psychic
abilities
after pinning alistair to the wall
interrogating him about lilith's plans
and discovering his lack of knowledge
sam
kills him so goes one of hell's absolute
nastiest creatures and one of
supernatural's most
memorable villains azazel isn't
the most powerful villain of all time
but the yellow eye demon is basically
the reason
john winchester became a hunter and the
reason he would go on to train his sons
in the family business
as hazel murdered sam and dean's mother
in supernatural's pilot episode
launching the winchester's long complex
journeys
as hunters of all that goes bump in the
night he's basically the reason
for the entire show as a prince of hell
one of the first
generation of demons created by lucifer
he's already no average bad guy
salt and holy water have nothing on him
the winchesters need a relic
to take down the zazel enter the cult a
revolver that could kill
virtually anything on the verge of
elimination dean shoots his hazel with
the colt and it works
like a charm he isn't quite that easy to
get rid of however he continues to haunt
the show
long past his demise a prince of hell
casts a very long shadow metatron is an
angel and
the scribe of god the only scribe to
have ever existed in fact
eons ago he was responsible for
transcribing god's word
gaining universe shaping information in
the process
he left heaven to hide among humans for
fear of what the archangels might do to
him in pursuit of that information
metatron is the creator of the angel
tablet which grants immense power to
those in contact with it
power he eventually exploits to expel
all angels from heaven
while this makes metatron unimaginably
powerful
his rule is short-lived and he ends up
locked in heaven's dungeon
for his crimes even though he's
eventually imploded into nothingness by
amara he still remains an
unforgettable character the alpha
vampire is the
first vampire and therefore the paragon
of
all vampires he knows of the ancient
leviathans and claims to remember
the continental divide which gives the
audience an idea of how old and powerful
he is
this is a creature who has survived for
millions of years as
the thing in the dark it would be an
understatement to say he's not to be
trampled with
it can be argued that the alpha vampire
isn't truly villainous as he mostly just
tries to live his best life as a unique
creature
but at the same time he did create
vampires
who have killed countless people in the
end
he falls to the legendary cult slayer of
entities otherwise
invulnerable
abaddon a knight of hell took down the
original men of letters
single-handedly she's the worst kind of
villain
at least from the winchester's
perspective massively powerful
and absolutely desperate for control
trained by the biblical cane
abaddon is an ancient threat well
accustomed to blood and mayhem
there is no one she won't possess
slaughter or maim in order to get what
she wants
after time traveling to the present day
she decides to pursue her biggest
plan yet become the queen of hell
like so many baddies she wants to rule
the world
through vast armies reserves of power
and
iron law too bad she comes across sam
and dean winchester
dean empowered by the mark of cain
eventually kills abaddon with the first
blade
a relic once described as the most
dangerous weapon on the planet lilith is
the first demon lucifer
ever created and the highest ranking
demon second only to lucifer himself
she's also the final seal of the 66 that
when broken
frees lucifer from his cage even her
death furthers a malicious agenda
how's that for a commitment to evil
lilith's villainous resume is long she
commands a demon army
murders dean with a hellhound and
tortures
countless humans although she arranges
for sam to kill her
breaking the 66th seal she's eventually
resurrected by god to retrieve the
equalizer a gun created by god that can
kill anything she destroys the gun and
delivers some
truly terrible news god's end game
is for sam and dean to kill each other
she's
effortlessly killed by the archangel
michael not long after
a short resurrection but one that
managed to shake the foundations of the
supernatural universe
rowena is arguably the most powerful
witch in the supernatural universe and
really not all that much of a bad guy
she often helps sam and dino it
sacrifices herself heroically and
even leaves her magical possessions to
sam after her demise
all this aside however she's season 10's
big bad power hungry in possession of
undeniably dark magic and willing to do
anything to benefit herself what makes
rowena
so powerful she is unstoppably clever
and thinks 10 steps ahead of everyone
else
for example when lucifer kills her she
manages to come back to life thanks to
resurrection spells she'd prepared in
advance
a later death is orchestrated to drag
the damned souls and demons freed by god
back to hell however it's later revealed
that she goes on to become the queen of
hell
so really she's not doing too badly in
the afterlife
crowley's resume is riddled with good
and evil
making him more of an anti-hero than a
true
out-and-out bad guy that said crowley is
a demon
he's power-hungry puts himself before
all others and is generally predisposed
towards nastiness
there are more powerful beings than
crowley but he's uniquely gifted
son of rowena he uses his smarts to
outwit other beings which
allows him to survive and outlive more
capable demons
and in the real world it also doesn't
hurt that he's a fan favorite
that's the sort of armor that tends to
keep a character healthy for years
no matter what kinds of shenanigans they
get themselves involved in
i don't read chinese talk about the
dumbing down of america
though he's been everything from a human
to the king of hell
crowley is a demon through and through
however his final act
is heroic he kills himself with an
angelic blade
to seal lucifer in an alternate
dimension light
or dark crowley is truly one of a kind
the mother of all monsters is named
eve and as her title suggests
eve created the very first versions of
each monster
the alphas eve is older than angels and
hell itself she loves her children
despite their monstrous natures and
while she cannot claim the highest body
count on the show
the amount of destruction and death her
children bring to the world
is unfathomable while eve is only around
for one season
she isn't a pushover there's only one
viable way to kill her
phoenix ash once the heroes find it dean
consumes the ash in a shot of liquor
then goads eve into biting him killing
her
once upon a time dick roman was a
billionaire businessman then he was
murdered
and replaced by the leader of the
leviathans creatures so powerful
god created purgatory to lock them away
forever
when a billionaire is combined with
god's first monsters
the result is one of the most powerful
beings on supernatural
leviathan dick roman isn't only one of
the oldest beings of the series
but he's also considered one of the most
powerful
naturally it takes a special weapon the
bone of a righteous mortal washed in the
three bloods of the fallen to take him
down for good
without this weapon the leviathans
likely would have taken over the world
despite the leviathan's legendary
brutality
leviathan dick roman only hangs around
for a single season
he might be an ancient figure of menace
but he goes up against
sam and dean and eon's old baddies don't
tend to fare too well against the
relentless brothers
raphael is an archangel one of the most
powerful creatures in the supernatural
universe
he can summon massive storms seems
omniscient and can black out
the entire eastern seaboard with a blink
he's ancient
unknowable and altogether scary
although raphael's time on supernatural
is fairly short-lived
he's one of the most powerful beings on
the show few things can
actually kill an archangel other
archangels
god amara or a handful of ancient
weapons
he's about as untouchable as a creature
can get which makes it all the more
impressive that castle is able to take
him down
even then he can only do it when
supercharged by all the souls
in purgatory like his brothers lucifer
raphael and gabriel
michael is an archangel however the
michael of the alternate universe known
as
apocalypse world is easily one of the
most powerful creations in the series
and one of the toughest villains sam and
dean
are ever forced to stop in his world one
torn apart by the absence of the
winchester brothers
he's a conqueror of unimaginable power
he's often referred to as the genghis
khan of its ruined landscape
as the eldest son of god alternate
michael
is arguably even more powerful than
lucifer himself
some of the ingredients the winchesters
need in the war against alternate
michael include
hunters castile rowena jack
gabriel lucifer and countless
others the battle is arduous but michael
is eventually defeated by jack
who exploits michael's hubris the
original
death in theory is in the top three
strongest beings on supernatural
death has existed from the beginning of
time
until his imminent demise the original
death however
wasn't necessarily an evil threat to the
winchesters
the primordial entity was only
interested in keeping
order eventually dean kills death with
his
own scythe and billy a reaper killed by
cashtill
is reincarnated and promoted as the new
death
billy assists the winchesters in their
endeavors and is considered neutral for
most of her time
his death she doesn't become a true
villain until late in the series
as the new death she inherits powers and
is among the most
potent entities and is the only being
that can read god's book but the shadow
drags her to a place of nothingness
known as the empty and her reign of
terror ends
at the height of her powers though billy
was one of the strongest villains on
supernatural
even if she wasn't considered an
antagonist for long
this is the last time you'll see me
again
until the end lucifer is one of the most
powerful villains on supernatural a
fallen archangel
he's the original ruler of hell and the
creator of demons
lilith the princes of hell the knights
of hell and
all other manner of dark creatures
spring from his power
despite his abilities in maliciousness
lucifer is actually a pretty
likable character sure the devil himself
is oozing with darkness but
this version of lucifer is at times laid
back
and comical had it not been for the
winchesters lucifer stood a very
real chance of taking over the world
eventually he's put down for good by
alternate michael and dean
his soul then dwells in the empty a
peaceful void where divine creatures
sleep forever
because living things don't stay dead on
supernatural for long
lucifer is resurrected by god but then
killed again
once and for all by michael with an
archangel blade
the darkness also known as amara
has existed since before the beginning
of time she's god's older sister
god had to create the archangels to
fight a war against her which
they eventually won and sealed her away
she's the primordial
origin point of all existence the
nothingness
that reigned before consciousness and
creation if either she or god is
destroyed
reality will cease to exist amara is
presumably stronger than
god yet god can with the help of others
stop her
as a pillar of reality itself she's the
most
powerful force the winchesters have ever
faced
luckily for the winchesters the darkness
leaves on her own terms
but then amara completely rewrites
history in the final season claiming
that she and god were born
simultaneously she allows god to absorb
her but luckily a juiced up jack absorbs
god's powers
and becomes the new almighty amara is
also absorbed by jack and they
live in harmony from an aspiring writer
to the creator of the universe
chuck has a long and complicated history
chuck is seen as a good guy
or at least a mutual party to the
winchesters for a good portion of the
series
it's not until the end of supernatural
when he's considered a full-on villain
and
in fact the big bad of the entire series
for a long time amara was the perceived
strongest being but
chuck being revealed as the big bad of
supernatural
counts for a lot as he's the final boss
that stands in the way of dean and sam's
happiness
at the height of his powers chuck
absorbs amara making him
an unstoppable force and the most
powerful villain
ever but alas it's short-lived jack
strips chuck of his powers and the
creator of the universe is left to live
out the rest of his days as a mere
mortal
the story to chuck's dismay continues
without him
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
supernatural are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you